stuff bedos et professeur à l'université
mcgill les codirecteurs du réseau de
recherche en santé buccodentaire et
osseuses bonsoir monsieur gosse que
pensez vous donc de cette proposition
aujourd'hui du npd je pense que c'est
une bonne idée
c'est un pas dans la bonne direction je
dirais que ce n'est pas une idée qui est
une nouvelle ça fait 50 ans qu'on en
parle
la commission rôle dans les années 60
avait déjà recommandé que les soins
dentaires soit inclus dans la système
médical
oui ça a été fait pour diverses raisons
a été retardé
donc je pense qu'on essaie de on
rattrape peut-être le temps maintenant
il faut savoir que c'est c'est utile une
couverture dentaire un tiers des
canadiens n'ont pas de couverture
dentaire la moitié des canadiens à
faible revenu n'a pas de couverture
dentaire
c'est justement ce cd besoin ce n'est un
besoin surtout pour les personnes qui
ont des caries dentaires ou des maladies
bucco dentaire et notamment les
personnes en situation de pour les
personnes à faible revenu oui vous nous
avez apporté un graphique qu'on va
regarder tout de suite pour voir qu'il
ya un écart important entre ceux qui ont
une couverture d'assurance dentaire et
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas alors on va voir
les résultats dans un esprit
malheureusement le pommeau et enfin
peut-être simplement le décrire c'est à
dire que les gens qui n'ont pas
d'assurance dentaire généralement
tendent à meaux et visiter dans tout ça
plus on est aisé plus on est aisé
financièrement plus on a tendance à en
plus on est nombreux à consulter le
dentiste
il faut savoir que le fait d'introduire
une couverture dentaire va réduire les
inégalités vont réduire les différences
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres tout le mois d'août où vont en
bénéficient mais pourquoi ça va réduire
les inégalités où les écarts
parce que les en fait les personnes en
situation de pauvreté ou les personnes à
faible revenu consultent moins souvent
que les autres et sont souvent bloqués
pour des pour des raisons d'ordre
financier donc le fait de bénéficier
d'une couverture dentaire va alors
permettre d'accéder à des services
donc on ce qu'on aperçoit ainsi que les
personnes à faible revenu
le consul très souvent mais avec le vi
nations ça augmente avec les personnes
en situation de pauvreté augmente encore
plus donc on réduit les différends ce
tournoi au même coup la graphique qui
vient d'arriver juste si on allait le
chercher à l'épicerie le voici avec
assurance dentaire 69 % des gens ont vu
un professionnel des soins dentaires
depuis un an exactement 89% des hauts
revenus 69% des faibles revenus et sans
assurance dentaire 50 % seulement des
faibles revenus et 78% des hauts revenus
ont consulté un professionnel des soins
dentaires geek l'écart ici est très
élevé ouais sans assurance l'écart
réduit
il n'est pas complètement réduit a
toujours une différence aller chez le
dentiste dépend d'une multitude de
facteurs le facteur financier est un des
facteurs majeurs mais ce n'est pas le
seul ça nous dit deux choses dans le
fond c'est à dire que si on a une
assurance dentaire ont tailladé
davantage absolument et ça nous dit
également que les gens à faible revenu
tendent à y aller - 1 que l'iran a eu
exactement même avec une couverture est
ce que de ne pas avoir de soins
dentaires gratuits ou universel entraîne
des enjeux de santé publique
présentement absolument il ya des enjeux
majeurs
il ya à peu près bien les chiffres
varient d'une étude à l'autre mais une
étude récente a montré que neuf millions
d'adultes canadiens avaient renoncé à
consulter le dentiste au cours des 12
derniers mois pour des raisons d'ordre
financier
9 millions c'est beaucoup de personnes
et donc c'est un impact on sait que la
moitié des personnes à faible revenu au
canada ont besoin de soins dentaires
ça coûterait cher à l'état que d'arriver
avec une couverture universelle
oui ça coûte cher je pense qu'une
estimation a été faite par
npd aujourd'hui je ne connais pas les
détails de c'était de leur calcul mais
évidemment ça coûte cher
les soins dentaires coûte cher les soins
médicaux coûte cher mais je dirais
également que l'école coûte cher système
public scolaire coûte cher système
universitaire coûte cher système des
médias publics coûtent cher c'est un
choix de société
combien va-t-on mettre dans la fente et
pourquoi on a décidé qu'en santé il y
avait une couverture universelle et que
les dents par exemple devant leurs
partisans ont été exclus à l'origine il
y avait un déficit en nombre de
dentistes dans les années 60 70
donc les universités certaines
universités ont été créés à québec par
exemple pour augmenter le nombre de
dentistes mais ça n'a pas été un sujet
majeur ça a été un peu mis de côté mais
on sait pas trop pourquoi peut-être
qu'ils avaient pas une demande très
important de la part de la population y
avait peut-être pas un soutien dans plus
de la profession inventaire donc je
pense que ça a été un peu mis de côté
c'est un parent pauvre mais ça fait des
années que des voix s'élèvent pour que
ya un accès universel pour les soins
dentaires
quels sont les défis pour implanter un
tel système partout au pays
bien que le défi majeur c'est une forme
d'acceptabilité est ce qu'on est prêt à
introduire un système comme celui ci ça
va coûter cher je pense que les gens
pensent que ce n'est pas réaliste
beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est pas
réaliste pourtant on est capable de
payer pour le système de santé
alors là ça où là aussi c'est un choix
de société il faut savoir que de toute
façon on met déjà beaucoup d'argent pour
les soins dentaires
une étude de l'iris il ya deux ans a
montré que chaque ménage au québec
dépensé 529 dollars par an pour les
services dentaires pour les soins
dentaires
donc l'argent est déjà me parler par les
canadiens pour se faire soigner les
dents
moi je par exemple je peux je paie une
prime d'assurance pour une assurance
privée
moi je préférerais mettre ma prime
donnée ma prime à l'état plutôt qu'à une
une assurance une compagnie d'assurances
privée voilà pour cette proposition du
npd monsieur bedos merci beaucoup aux
gens pris assez bien